evening everyone and welcome to fox news
primetime
hi i'm brian kilmeade the left has spent
the last year as you know airing out
america's dirty laundry on the world
stage and now our adversaries are
rubbing our face in it
it's not been easy watching americans
criticizing america day in and day out
the radical left in many cases has had a
field day ridiculing our past
mocking our present and seemingly
determined to undermine our future
we're not going to make america great
again
it was never that great
when i hear these things about let's
make america great again i think to
myself well exactly when did you think
america
was great there's things that are
savagely wrong in this country
injustice has grown to be normal in our
country and it's time for us
to work together to get folk woke
well was he crying well our fighting has
been mostly internal it's clear our
enemies have been watching and we're
giving them ammunition to attack us and
deflect
from their own atrocities and their own
transgressions we saw it happen back in
march
in the first u.s china meeting over in
alaska remember this we condemned their
uyghur genocide and their steamrolling
of hong kong
and what did they do they raided
american diplomats using u.s
leftist rhetoric many people within the
united states
actually have little confidence in the
democracy of the united states
and the challenges facing the united
states in human rights
are deep seated they did not just emerge
over the past four years such as black
lives matter
it did not come up only recently the
united states does not have the
qualification to say that it wants to
speak to china
from a position of strength embarrassing
instead of standing strong in the face
of those viled accusations the body
administration chose to make our
problems in my estimation even worse
apologizing for america's inherent
systematic
racism erecting black lives matter flags
at u.s embassies around the globe
letting every country know how bad we
think we
are vladimir putin has also been taking
notes when the russian president was
asked if he killed political dissidents
he deflected he pointed the finger back
at america
we don't have this kind of habit of
assassinating anybody that's one
number two is i want to ask you did you
order the
assassination of the woman who walked
into the congress and who was shot and
killed by a policeman
do you know that 450 individuals were
arrested after entering the congress
and they didn't go there to steal a
laptop they came with political demands
isn't that persecution for political
opinions
wow russia and china are able to attack
us the way because this way because we
wrote the script for them we punctuated
their copy
think about it this way every time our
leaders publicly criticize our country
we look like a family fistfighting on
our front lawn and guess what
all of our neighbors are watching and
they're judging us and our bad neighbors
like putin and she are taking notes
looking for ways to rob our house
while we're not paying attention the
more divided we are as a country
the less stable we look on the
international stage tomorrow's geneva
summit with vladimir putin is the
biggest foreign policy test of joe
biden's early presidency
do you see it all wraps together biden
needs to project strength
and confidence in the face of a man
who's gotten the best of our last five
presidents
how's that going so far vladimir putin
laughed at the suggestion that you had
called him a killer
is that still your belief sir that he is
a killer
the first question i'm laughing too
they actually uh
well look i mean he has made clear that
uh
the answer is i believe he is in the
past
essentially acknowledged that he was uh
there are certain things that he would
do or did do
does that sound like strength if biden
wants to prove that america is really
back like he says
he needs to do what he promised and
unite the country stop our national
infighting
and don't use the global stage to score
domestic political points
the republican party is vastly
diminished in numbers
the leadership of the republican party
is
fractured we won't say anything nice
about our own country
who will i promise you vladimir putin
won't hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else